- [Voiceover] g is an exponential function
with an initial value of -2.
So, an initial value of -2,
and a common ratio of 1/7,
common ratio of 1/7.
Write the formula for g(t).
Well, the fact that it's
an exponential function,
we know that its formula is going to be
of the form g(t) is equal
to our initial value
which we could call A,
times our common ratio
which we could call r,
to the t power.
It's going to have that form.
And they tell us what
the initial value is.
It's -2.
So this right over here is -2.
And we know that the common ratio is 1/7.
So this is 1/7.
So let me just write it
again a little bit neater.
g(t) is going to be equal to
our initial value, -2,
times
times our common ratio, 1/7,
to the t power.
And hopefully this makes sense.
Initial value is this number.
Well, if t is equal to 0,
then 1/7 to the zero power is 1.
And so g(0), you could do that
at time as being equal to zero
if your t is time, would be equal to -2.
So that would be our initial value.
And then if you think about it, every time
you increase t by one,
you're going to mulitply by 1/7 again.
And so, the ratio between successive terms
is going to be 1/7.
And so that's why we call that
the common ratio.
Hopefully, you found that interesting.